hello
no sale on white pandas
asking about this so i don't know that
was the first thing i saw
uh harold has
the socks on
the comma socks the infamous comma socks
check it out
this isn't selling you guys i don't know
what will and how to
i feel like if you just on the floor and
like we just look at him that works too
make driving chill
it's also upside down oh there we go
here we go
yeah that's nice that should have been
the thumbnail oh well
all right
let's go for a stream talk about the
black friday sale
how are the how are the socks harold do
they come from oh they're unbelievably
comfortable you don't even understand
i can feel the coma three through my
toes
that sounds amazing
[Applause]
yeah so for those who don't know
there's uh you have the crawl out here
nice right there there's a black friday
sale going on and it's uh very exciting
because it's the first sale ever on the
comma three it's definitely the best
time to get a comma three if there's
ever been a good time to get one
it is now and i'm still locked down
there we go
out there
here it is it's a comma three
all right
so comma three is two hundred dollars
off for black friday
which is wild
uh so it's 19.99 under 2 000. the
cheapest comma 3 ever
there is ever a time to get a comma
three now is it
oh yeah you guys know historically black
friday sales have been the cheapest time
to get coma devices
that's never gonna change
yep
so uh if you've been considering it
i recommend now's the time
oh and this is also uh our end-to-end
branch over here
made some improvements since last time
so
go for a drive we can talk about that
and just the general progress we've been
making in research a little update yeah
we ship all over the world
uh
ship with dhl
[Music]
stopping for that one didn't get that
yet um but yeah so 200 off of comma 3
and then 100 off a comma two if you
happen to want one but really you should
get a comma three during this sale if
you're at all thinking about it if you
have a supported car it's really a
no-brainer it's open pile's amazing
it is really amazing
and um
yeah if you've got uh i've got too many
devices you know there's always another
purpose you can get a comma body and
those come out
yeah i'm very excited about those
sometime next year probably
there's a lot of unknowns about it but
it should be pretty exciting
all right yes let us know in the chat if
you uh buy a comma three during the sale
during the stream right now and we'll
we'll shout you out
uh
yeah what else should we should we talk
about just some some general updates
yeah give some updates on research what
everyone's working on over there
yeah so we uh just released we're just
in the process of releasing xerate 11.
that's mostly just some bug fixes and
nothing too big but we've got a lot of
cool things in the works we were working
on new sounds you guys can check that
out if you want there's some branches
with the new sounds
should sound a lot better on the comma
three so those are pretty exciting
um then our research we're
we're working a lot on end to end
longitudinal this is uh
maybe the latest iteration of that
um we've got some pretty good
improvements coming to the lateral
models the big big complaints about that
were
the exit diving and like it not really
behaving well around exits in general
even if it doesn't take it just kind of
swerving towards it and we made some
really good improvements uh to that
mitchell
uh found some pretty cool tricks we're
just still in the process of verifying
some stuff it's always a big process to
make sure there's no regressions but
that's looking very very good and it's
going to be just improvements and
lateral all around
and especially the exit behavior should
be so much improved
mitchell made a data set of
some 20 complaints
of just like
it having issues around exits and then
the new model and those specific
all right we're back you didn't miss
anything
we're just still still driving
still driving
this is end-to-end this is uh the
machine learning deciding how fast to
drive here
i mean i was just kind of following this
car so i guess it's relatively easy but
we'll see later on some turns it should
hopefully slow down appropriately and
get to see some
the real ai in action that'd be exciting
uh what branch is this someone asked i
mean if if you have to ask i recommend
you don't use it
makes sense
see if you can find it yourself
what's the purpose of the body it stands
there
yeah it looks cool
yeah it stands there
that's it
oh what's happened them oh we've also
really been there's been a lot of
complaints about just general how open
pile longitudinal is and stop and go
um
so i've been trying to work on that and
seeing if you can come up with a better
policy that matches more like the kind
of drive humans do it stop and go it
should hopefully be a lot more
comfortable
i think on the highway our long-term
policy with lead cars is really quite
good but it's stop and go i think
there's still a lot of things to be
improved
so working actively on that as well
[Music]
that's super exciting
yeah can you tell we're in the corolla
because of the road noise
yeah it's so loud very loud very loud
car
uh
this is nice though this is like a
pretty good yeah it's pretty comfortable
right comfortable follow distance it's
it's definitely closer than uh open
pilot is today but it you know this
guy's going pretty slow so it makes
sense yeah let's drive into it
yeah
any any work on big model going on in
the research team oh yeah so we're
working on big model i mean big model's
been this thing that's been pushed off
because every time we tried it we didn't
really see much benefit from it like and
you know if we can't see that big model
would improve a lot of the cases that
openpilot is having trouble then i mean
why would we spend our time you know
doing that when we could be doing other
things right so
um but now that with the end-to-end
longitudinal you need the big model to
see the lights for example to go from uh
from a stopped uh stop light to when it
turns green so now there's there's more
incentive to go for the big model so
we're working on that again
i think it'll actually ship this time
what do you think
i think so i mean there's a lot of work
involved but i think now there's really
a compelling reason to work on it
because of the uh
because of what we mentioned the
the green light problem i mean just in
general for longitudinal having context
is quite quite useful so i was actually
intending to take this exit but i mean
you know didn't really want to take over
so
just we'll just see where it takes us
there you can see he's been doing all
this slow down it's been doing all the
speed management around these turns and
so far that's fine maybe it doesn't have
enough look at that all right they did
it yeah it slowed down a bit yeah slow
down for this turn this is all just the
mall doing it um i haven't taken over i
mean since we got on the highway so
yeah it's pretty incredible i think this
is very promising
this is that's super promising right
there that was that was amazing i don't
remember it ever working for any turn so
yeah no we definitely made some
improvements i think since last time you
uh
you drove it it's a little bit slow to
get up to speed like this for example i
really should be a bit more aggressive
about it but
uh
it's not not unsafe it's just a bit you
know not the speed that i would drive
right
car detected in blind spot pretty cool
part of that's also because it just
doesn't have the big model view so it
doesn't really have the context as much
about the cars moving around it since it
only sees like straight ahead if it's
all the cars passing it it's usually a
bit more inspired to go faster
yeah that makes sense
man that's super cool and you're telling
me n10 longitudinal will eventually come
to common threes everywhere hopefully
yeah future
it's a it's going to be kind of an
experimental process to see how we can
ship it and and which parts will be
shipped because i mean you don't just
want to ship full end to end because
there's comes with some disadvantages
um
but yeah maybe we'll ship behind a
toggle first or something when i think
the easiest feature that i think i want
to ship first is
uh when you go from a stop if there's a
stopped car in front of you and he
accelerates there's a limit to how fast
the open pedal accelerates now just
because of you know we want comfortable
cruise acceleration
but with end to end we can see if the
model is asking for a lot more
acceleration we can increase those
limits so then the crews should still be
comfortable because the model knows that
like cruise acceleration um but then
when there's a stopped car pulling away
it will be more aggressive i think
people really like that that's i think a
big source of disengagement for myself
as well
yeah me too that would be amazing
uh so yeah you can get this comma three
not this exact one but you can get a
comma three for 19.99
from now until cyber monday so you know
really uh better to get it sooner rather
than later i'd say um if you get it
sooner rather than later you'll get
those cool comma socks that harold
showed off at the beginning of the
stream we have a very limited amount of
those and uh yeah there's there's 69
value so go ahead and oh it's such a
steal this sucks 200 off and the socks
yeah i mean it could have been could
have been no deal and just socks and it
would have still been i know the best
deal on a combat three so
yeah guys the best best price you'll
ever get for a comma three you get it
now that's right yeah
uh yeah they'll be shipping in one to
two weeks uh we're working on making
them right now so
we sold a lot
so far
oh yeah 2k socks
yeah
i don't know if the stocks are worth
that much maybe they are
um i know is there anything else we
should uh talk about yeah anyone have
any questions about what research is
working on or anything yeah no this is a
technical question
well doesn't have the torque for this so
yeah
but i think the you know the speed it
took it was pretty reasonable yeah i
mean look i still haven't disengaged
since i got on the highway that's
impressive yeah cut that guy off but you
know
the model is not generous
but yeah i mean look at this isn't this
incredible this is the power of machine
learning guys you guys labeled this data
by driving the speeds you guys like and
now the model
has a little bit of peace of every one
of you
that's so cute
so distributed uh
distributed driving
yeah i'm really impressed right now
because i mean this almost looks like a
highway obviously we can tell and i'm
sure the model can tell but it's not
because it doesn't have more lanes
you know there's sidewalks and things
you can see the speed's been set at uh
you know 70
oh here potentially guess we're going on
a turn
i mean it's not going to make the turn
but it's slow down for it so yeah it's
got it's got that going for it all right
let me take over here
um
that was impressive we had we're engaged
for so long i'm also gonna go to
set up some nav someone asked somewhere
yeah that
make sense i have no clue where we are
but that's okay look at this isn't this
incredible it's incredible
wow there's so many stopped cars around
so it's all right we'll take over for
this let's learn here
yeah someone asked how to navigate on
open pilots coming that's really pushed
back until we get end to end
longitudinal and
uh in a in a good state because at that
point really all you have to do is uh
you know put in the navigation
directions but until then it would be
difficult to take you know exits and
everything by itself if it can't slow
down properly i mean yeah if it can't
take like aggressive turns by itself
it's kind of unclear how useful navigate
an open pilot so we kind of want to get
that working first
yeah but as you can see we're working
very hard on that so
um
this is this is the best demo yet it
barely worked before
we're working on it it's making progress
yeah it did slow down for that turn yeah
fully
no yeah the really powerful thing about
this idea is it it costs us so much less
time to improve this because i mean if
the model's doing all the work it's just
trying to figure out how you guys drive
and then trying to mimic that we don't
have to hand tune any follow distances
or anything like that
it's a little bit
lazy here but all right so i'll help it
again for this turn but longitudinal
we'll just let it do its thing
it's pretty good
we'll see if we can get back on the
highway and everything without uh
yeah without doing anything crazy here's
the turn by turn directions which you
get on a comma three
pretty cool if you have prime you can
just uh you know put in an address on on
the comic connect website and it goes
right up to the comma three wirelessly
yeah i can actually use it quite a lot
that is really good especially just if
you just hack consent your work all the
time
where i'm going anyway
this is a comfortable stop too harold
yeah so i mean this is the beautiful
thing about this end-to-end longitudinal
stuff is we've really been struggling
with finding like follow distances and
cost functions
that uh you know a human finds
comfortable it's very unclear what
humans optimize for when they come to
like a full stop or when they're
controlling the breaks but here the
model is just figuring out what humans
doing and trying to mimic it so we don't
have to do any like
any work just trying to figure out what
humans find comfortable breaking and it
just does it all itself so that's why we
can get so much more like natural
feeling stops and
breaking behavior without actually
having to
tune anything
[Music]
yeah we're looking at end to end
longitudinal
again it like slowed down before the
lead triangle came like there was some
stopped traffic up ahead and it starts
slowing down before the the radar picked
it up oh yeah for sure yeah yeah i know
it it's it can definitely tell like if
it seems like a big blob of cars and red
lights that you know it's probably a
good idea to start slowing down i mean
that's what we do as humans as well yeah
someone asked is it using radar or pure
vision
so on this branch it's almost
exclusively vision but there are some
extreme limits the radar sets but in
this drive we've pretty much never hit
those
so basically everything you've seen so
far is vision only end-to-end
basically no
no
lead policy being involved and no
no radar
super cool
again if i don't know if this hasn't
sold you on getting a comma 3 i don't
know what will i mean
it's doing an amazing job yeah guys i
think i mean this is some of the realest
ai you can experience today
yeah i'm not sure what other products
you can get out here that uh that have
like this kind of real world ai that you
can just use and
like google voice recognition but that's
not as cool
sea world
i didn't get those sounds on the branch
we want to see if we can get those on so
you guys can experience those oh yeah i
just don't have a torque here
[Music]
a little slow but also like i feel like
the model view of this is probably like
yeah very unusable i mean this is
exactly what the big model is going to
be for like it just doesn't see the turn
it has no idea if you're coming to a
stop or coming into an on-ramp
so hopefully big model will really give
it that context
yeah
i don't know is there any other
questions people have about black friday
or the stuff we're working on
anything like that yeah did anyone buy
right now because it's a it's a great
time to get a comma three i just you
should check the the car list again
because we support over 150 vehicles now
so even if your car wasn't supported in
the past i mean we support so many cars
it's ridiculous
so many modern hyundai kia genesis
uh toyotas hondas we even support a
mazda now it's a new brand port that's
coming out with zero eight eleven
uh so yeah the list just keeps growing
for cars that work with open pilot
really exciting and if anyone's having a
bad experience and wants to work on the
tune of their car quadmus made a tool
that makes it really easy to uh kind of
see if the tune of your car is bad and
if there's anything you can do about it
um
so yeah if anyone's willing to give that
a shot or think their car could improve
some tuning give it a good check
yeah somewhere in the open pilot repo
some tuning scripts someone asked if it
would slow down
if uh
you're going alongside like slower cars
i mean humans do that so that's the goal
right for sure i mean you've seen this
drive most of the time open piles
engaged and i mean this set speed set to
80 miles an hour so it's just driving
exactly how fast it wants
i was driving 40 miles an hour on this
kind of road here i mean that's all just
or just learned and it definitely will
slow down around other traffic as well
which is i mean really the promising
thing about it it's just so annoying
that if the lead cuts out then it just
floors it even if there's cars around
so
yeah very promising very promising yeah
if you order now it'll ship in one to
two weeks you know we're gonna do our
best to get them out as soon as possible
but give a little leeway just in case uh
but yeah we'll be working hard on
on that
yeah a lot of vw cars there are
yeah do those all have longitudinal as
well
not yet jason's working on but they have
just stuck longer to them yes
jason this will inspire you you're
already working on it so keep it up
yeah so here you can see in this case
like there's no other cars around and
this is all just what the mall thinks is
a good idea
yeah this is perfect real machine
learning guys real machine learning
there's no bicycle detectors there's no
cone detectors no cart i mean i guess
there are car detectors but they're
supposed to not be doing anything
yeah just
just the model in the road yeah exactly
this is the freest the model has ever
been we removed all the cages
just a
free model on the open road
i haven't even got a wheel shot yet
because of how where the mic is so i got
a wheel shot so everyone can see
we're not faking it
there's some some barriers coming up
here i'm just gonna oh yeah are you
ready to take over
maybe nudge that a little bit oops
i just wanted to be ready
a little bit uncomfortable when you get
so close yeah
hit torque limit what are people saying
let's see
[Music]
jason said he's gonna put the n10 lawn
branch
and drive it in about 20 minutes this is
awesome
yeah it's a little bit jerky still i
think we haven't really worked on like
the
tuning we're just making sure that the
models kind of work architecturally but
made some good progress on that
yep but yeah end to end guys end to end
it's uh been comma's dream since day one
i think we've got the lateral part
mostly done um and now it's part for
time for part two
uh it's probably the most exciting part
because that means it's going to be
complete
yeah
yes the stuff the socks are still in
stock
that's hard to say but the socks are
still in stock so i mean place your
order down
not that many socks left
not that many i don't have an exact
number but there's not many socks left
and we're not ordering more socks either
so
uh someone asked if you're using the
road texture for anything uh yeah if you
if you check out the new repo
depth 10k right
yeah depth 10k
i'm just going to take over here it's
again can't see much but i probably feel
the vibram again yeah depth 10k is
pretty cool because the come with the
comma 3 cameras you can see road texture
you can see you know potholes everything
you could never see these things with
the comma 2 camera it was just so blurry
so
yeah comment what's the what's the goal
of depth 10k if you were to
explain it harold
um
yeah just i mean we just wanted to open
source data set so that people can also
you know train depth nets
like it's appealing to a lot of people
that are interested in machine learning
and i mean the kind of driving models
are not that accessible to either train
or or really work on
but stuff like the depth net and the
segment you can do yourself and uh i
mean we're very interested in depthness
because
there's quite a few reasons devnets are
useful one is that for a model to
understand the depth of the scene it
also has to understand its own motion or
can give you information about its own
motion so it's a you can if you train
the depthness end-to-end it's a
completely end-to-end way of
understanding the motion of the car and
the road which can be very helpful tool
for just processing in general
um that's one part and the other is if
we understand the depth of the scene we
can make a 3d map of the scene and move
the camera around
for simulation
so i don't know if you guys have seen
like the simulator that we train in we
train in a simulator where you can kind
of move the car around so that you can
kind of deviate from the trajectory the
human drove and with depnets you can
have very good reconstructions when you
move the camera which i mean the better
the reconstruction is the better uh the
mobile train so
that's kind of the motivation there
for localization in like an end-to-end
machine learning way and for uh
simulation
cool that's a great explanation
some people were just asking what end to
end is it basically just means uh drive
like a human you know
it's the easiest way to put it if you
really boil it down
yeah
yeah if
for this drive i mean basically if what
we would normally be driving an open
pilot we explicitly detect the car with
the machine learning model and then we
keep some distance away from that car
depending on our speed and their speed
and then the end-to-end way is we just
train a model to understand how fast
humans drive and how humans accelerate a
decel rate and then just tries to mimic
that so this entire drive even right now
open pilot has been trying to mimic what
a human would have done in these cases
which is completely different from the
non-end-to-end way which is just detect
the lead car and stay some distance away
from them
you can see here for example that the
lead car is pulling away and this is
much larger than the following distance
you would usually keep but because there
is relatively slow moving traffic around
it's not really incentivized to speed up
and this is exactly what we want we
don't want the lead here to pull away
and then you to floor it past and
overtake cars at the left
so
that's kind of
the beauty of this whole end-to-end
thing yeah this really is with the flow
of everybody yeah it's like we're not
we're not going like 80 past all these
people you just get that pretty well
merge conflicts
[Music]
pretty cool stuff
it was that was great did you see the
flood harold
yeah yeah
our highway flooded
wild stuff
um
what a successful drive
so yeah coming soon to common threes
you know with that wide uh
that wide camera it's really going to
help us do more
cool stuff on the research department
soon tm
tm this guy didn't indicate the model is
supposed to understand that
but you know how like when he merged
over like he didn't slam the brakes
either no
i mean it's it was going to be super
smooth right this is also it's gonna be
as smooth as humans are the problem with
the end-to-end policy is kind of hard to
make it aggressive and it needs to be
aggressive make it smoother it needs to
be smooth but i mean with the normal
lead policy with the end-to-end just
figure it out yep yeah someone was like
saying how is it uh how is it like
conveyed what the model is doing and you
know we we hired a a ui ux person
recently sent an offer uh so i think you
know when everything's full end to end
the ui might look different than it
looks today
yeah so you got to convey what the model
thinks
you know like the path is really good at
that for lateral i think but yeah
there's probably some way to do that for
longitudinal so stay tuned
yeah i don't know if you guys have ever
played drift 3 but you know when you
play on like coach mode or whatever it
shows you the path it shows if you've
got to accelerate or decelerate
i don't know i'm not a designer
that's what i have in mind heavy too
that's what i was thinking
but it's true we do have to convey
pretty clearly what the model's thinking
you know we're moving away from these
kind of literal clues like uh cues like
lane lines and cars and to something
more holistic and then
i mean there are ways we can ask the
model about why it's doing things but
it's
just got to figure out how to convey
that clearly
yep
yeah i guess we can do one more recap uh
the black friday sales going now until
cyber monday but the socks are very
limited if you want to get free socks
uh
you want to show the show a sock
oh yeah
keep my right foot ready for uh for a
take over here but uh there it is
driving chill
the other side has a comma on it go to
the beginning of the stream if you want
to see that
uh they're really good socks yeah the
socks aren't in the store right now you
can only get the socks by getting a
comma two or common three during the
black friday sale and it's 200 off a
comma three that's the cheapest the
common three is ever gonna be so if
you're at all on the fence you have a
car you wanna upgrade from an eon comma
two whatever i think now is the best
time to do that
and uh
yeah definitely
get one if you're interested i mean
great stuff is coming in the future i'm
excited guys i'm really excited i think
you guys should be excited too i mean
you guys have seen this drive i took
over
only only maybe like five to ten times
it slowed down for turns it slowed down
for traffic like a human all by itself
um i think i think it's just
the future guys this is the future and
it's it's coming
all the way future is now oh it's not
seeing this it doesn't see him or does
it oh it sees it now
well i managed to do it nice got a merge
no problem
someone said i love mine yeah but it's a
beautiful device it really is the
screen's really nice the cameras are
super high quality
uh you know there's a reason it costs so
much uh it's a very high quality device
you know custom designed hardware cheap
to make these
exactly
would buy it if i didn't have a common
two
well yeah any new people just got a
comma three you know it's amazing but if
you
haven't ever tried open pilot and you're
like man i i don't know i really need to
experience it for myself we still are
offering the the try a two upgrade to a
comma three program so you can buy a
comma two right now try it for up to 90
days and if at any point within those 90
days you're like oh i want to comment
through i should have got that uh you
can just pay the difference so that's a
pretty cool program too on comma.i slash
compare
but i would just get a comma three at
this price come on say we're going to be
this price it's never
so the guy's asking like when is this
coming have we ever answered a question
with a date like that
it's kind of hopeful though
coming in 61 days it's gonna release
this is all experimental guys we wanted
to come as soon as possible
but uh yeah i mean we're pretty
transparent about what we're working on
the end-to-end long tunnel is a big push
right now so
i mean more it's more likely features
like that are gonna come out before
navigate on open pilot i mean and then i
think once like highway slow down for
turns and exit taking is really really
good i think then navigate and open
pilot makes really a lot of sense for
the next step
but guys i mean we've never given really
timelines or deadlines we're trying as
hard as we can
it's all very experimental very hard to
uh
have exact timelines when nobody's ever
done anything before like this so yeah
there's real people working on it yeah
so we're not just like
keep it in a branch somewhere and never
never touch it again we're actively
working on it um so it's very exciting
it doesn't break for green lights it
goes right through them it does yeah it
goes through stop signs sometimes too so
i guess that needs to be worked on but
hopefully the field of view will help
yes
any plans to remove set speed in the
future i mean no you always want to be
able to tell the maximum speed you want
to just go wild
yep
uh
yeah you really need a car with lane
keep assist and adapter cruise control
are there some people who've gotten
really old cars to work but you
basically need to put in a new electric
uh power steering rack and everything
no we don't break for overpass either
yeah overpress i mean that's a that's a
common radar problem right because this
most radars they don't tell you the
altitude that uh metal object is being
detected so you know for example the
overpass right in front of us has a
metal on the railing
and unless you filter that out somehow
for the radar that looks exactly the
same as a stopped car right ahead of you
so that's why this can be an issue but i
mean we've since
since i don't know quite a long time
over a year now two years basically
always had the vision model decide um
whether there is a lead car in front of
you or not and
which
car that's detected by the model would
match for certain radar point so
everything is really controlled by the
vision and by the model so that's what i
mean that's why we don't really have
those kind of radar only false positives
yep
cool
well good stuff yeah i think that's all
i got unless there's any other questions
so i got this is the smoothest stop and
go drive i've ever had with open pilot
like usually you're like
you know because it's it's right floor
and then it's gonna
you know
some guy moved up five feet and it it's
ready yeah but now it's really
in the relationship because of the users
man you guys labeled this
this is uh this is you guys in action
thanks for driving well everybody the
comma fleet combined yes
wow look at that i mean
that was amazing
um a b isn't affected by anything like
this like the toyota does the av yeah i
know there's no uh end-to-end av no uh
at least not the different one then we
do have a vision-based aab that will
trigger if it thinks there's going to be
very high deceleration according to the
model but it's not
perfect
here's where we work san diego city back
home back home great well yeah we'll see
you all in another stream at some point
but really get that comma three now if
you're at all interested be sure to
share the deal with your friends anyone
who has a compatible car it's really the
time to get one right now so
i highly recommend getting one uh well
it's 200 off
exactly
and the socks
best socks
cool see you guys see you guys bye
peace